step away
all right keisha hey keisha where'd you
grow up where are you from
memphis tennessee memphis and tell me
about your childhood you had both your
parents when you were a kid
well i had my mom dad was in and out my
mom was a single parent
seven children i'm the oldest
you know i kind of played older sister
mama
mom went to work right so i kind of
been an older person and how would you
describe your childhood
well i had an awesome childhood i wasn't
one for anything like i said my mom was
the
mom and dad she took real good care of
us it was
seven of a stabbing above us i had an
awesome childhood
no abuse no no abuse where i was
molested
my stepdad by my stepdaddy he molested
me when i was a child
i tried to tell everyone but then i want
to believe it
yeah it happens a lot yeah it's time to
get older you know it finally came out
i went to all type of crisis and classes
and
here i am today yeah so how far did you
go in school
i graduated from 12th grade say i said
half
and then where'd you go after that
nowhere i just started working
in the warehouse i'm a machine operator
and what led you into this line of work
well because i'm a single parent myself
i have two children dad ran off on me
when i first got pregnant you raised him
on your own so i'm raising two children
on my own
doing the best in my ability and
i'm just taking one day at a time i'm
going to work
you've been doing this uh you know about
six years now and you find this money is
easier to live with you know you well
yeah because i'm a
single parent you know any type of way i
can try to you know
make me ends meet you know i go for it
and you're doing without a pimp well i
had a pimp when i was like
15. kind of took me out of town
left me i came back and
didn't ever date a pimp again yeah took
all my money
beat me just let me out there for dead i
found and found my way
and been here ever since and how much
money will you make
i won't make it thousands of dollars but
like i said he was
taking this stealing and all i didn't
make and
he was abusive yeah you know i didn't
give it to him you know he beat me
real bad for me to get it that means i'm
out on the street
any and everything that was a 15 year
old girl feed thing yeah but
how old are you now i'm 31 31 and how
much do you make
well um it's harder now right it is
it's kind of hard now because i'm kind
of slow down and i'm kind of mature
and like i said i'm raising children of
my own yeah
so i'm just trying to set a good example
yeah
and there are drugs a part of your life
well i'm a trap
pills here and there didn't succeed with
it
so now i smoke marijuana
when i was 15 he tried to give me some
bad drugs but once i found out what it
was i kind of
weighed myself off went to an a.a class
and ever seen it again good for you yeah
you've been arrested doing this yes i
have
for assault defending myself
nothing major and the the guys that pick
you up have you ever had
hard times with them bad experiences yes
sir some some
some guys you know want to pay you they
didn't take the money back
so you know i had to fight my way out of
a lot of situations
yeah you know try to stay alive because
the gas we'll pay you then
take the money back truck drivers
you know leave you out there
leaving me to find you know my way back
does does this life get you down
sometime sir do you get depressed
i do yeah uh very often
but i'm so thankful and grateful that
i'm here today
and i have my life due to you know i've
been through so much
and i was molested at a younger age so
and it was about my stepdad
so do you feel like that kind of
changed the course of your life it did
it
i was going to class getting counseling
and
trying to overcome it because like i
said a lot of people didn't want to
believe
you know it when i found him you know
when he got older it found it came on
now
he was doing this yeah and does that
affect your relationships with men now
as an adult well some guys
i just try to take a look you know easy
some gas
you know they come to come off a little
harsh
you know i try to do everything but a
book now
yeah what's the hardest part of this
life
for you well trusting people
you know trusting people because when i
was a child like i said i was
molested and going through so much you
know people didn't believe
me so you know i just have trust the
issue
yeah well it's also the circle of people
that you're interacting with
on the street or you know the tricks the
pimps the cops
the other girls everybody is like
looking out for themselves right
everybody's looking out for that still
and and you're just like it's doggy dog
out there right
it seems you care are you going with you
yeah
i have license to care i haven't met a
person yet in memphis that doesn't
yeah everybody's packing something here
yeah life
i feel i feel very vulnerable here yeah
i mean i'm the
i'm the only white person in this hood
and i'm the only one without a ghost oh
yeah
i'm an idiot do you recall the very
first time you did this
back in southaller
tell me about that well i was with this
photographer
i don't know how it seems to be he came
off very nice
yeah they do that then when we get on
they still behind closed doors
we do that yeah it's like uh you know
you let me get you the [ __ ] if i want
you to have the [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying don't just try to come off and
throw yourself out to me hey i'm like
hey i thought i was here for one thing
and
you know you're really trying to [ __ ]
so you know i'm just trying to be
careful you know on those tips no
but that was that was for money yeah it
was for money still but you know he
didn't tell me like you know he told me
he was like an acting thing
yeah but then when we get over here and
close those oh we got to do this we got
to do this then yeah
i just want so much you got to watch
those photographers yes
they're sleazy bastards yes and i mean
like
i mean it was a lot for me it was a lot
more like that they're not all like that
yes and i'm like i thought you was
trying to take picture of my
body you know i was the exotic dancer
for many years as well are you you're a
stripper yeah
and how is i was working as a prostitute
different than working as a stripper
well it's a whole lot different because
you know
us as women we work in the environment
clubs
we can't see a you know [ __ ] head can't
[ __ ] tricks
it's strictly dancing yeah so you know
i'm off of it
yeah i'm off with it a little more
dignity being a stripper than
i mean people love seeing that ass so
you know
i just get up there and do what i got to
do you know my lips
bring me out anyway so yeah you're
beautiful yeah i stand there
you know gas be you know a trick though
so you know i don't have a problem with
a lot of times i prefer to dance you
know what i'm saying
yeah [ __ ] and [ __ ] suck all the
things
do you think you're addicted to this
life now i'm not gonna lie i am
yeah all right there's seen so much
money come through and everybody is
i don't think that if if they say no i
don't buy it
right i mean the temptation to just
make that fast buck come on then how are
you going to say no i'm going to go back
to my job at the
moment grocery store the job we got to
wait every
week every two weeks you know it may be
something i need you know you know are
you secretly hoping that
some prince charming comes along and say
that i am yeah i am
i just hope somebody in my house will
come sweep me on my feet
you know take care of my kids
make your life easier just make my life
easier i don't have to struggle so hard
like i said i'm a single parent i'm
raising kids on my own
father being left for us so
you've been loved before sir you've been
in love before yes i
am heart gap broke so many times
i just throw it on there yeah
yeah how do you think
doing this for a living has changed you
it has shines me tremendously it really
has it has changed me tremendously
i mean in a good way very good way
because like i was struggling with so
much homeless out on the streets
from here there they're here with my
cheers and hold seals
shields you know and i'm like you know
you got to do something about it
you know so i prefer you know i got up
on my booty gap at my duty
and got the making away
yeah does it does it build your
self-esteem or does it tear it down
no it be it's not safe it does yes yeah
because the guys worship you and they
pay you lots of money and
yeah come back you have regulars yes i
do
yeah i'm sure yeah i do
what what is this done for your like
what you what you think of men
i mean you respect men less because of i
don't
not all men because i can't you know i
came a long way i learned to forgive and
you know forget
you know i can't base my past off
you know the future you know i have ran
some good gas out
because you know i was so messed up you
know went through so much in my past
so i kind of came around to trying to
you know
beg socialize and talking and open more
up to gas
you know than i normally would have
it was just a struggle for me i had to
get something you know get it done
myself
do you think if your childhood was
different if you hadn't been
molested if your dad was in the picture
if things like that were
different for you your life would look
very different today yeah i probably
think i would um
did more been success for it more yeah
yeah you know you probably would have
your self-worth would have been higher
so you would never have considered maybe
this kind of work
right i would have never been that yeah
being able in the lifestyle
you know here and there out across
country
you you must at some point stand back
and look at your life and go manchester
is so crazy here i am going out to work
here i am
you can get killed right you have kids
you're trying to raise right but you're
out there risking your life
right it's a nutty way to go with your
life it is
it's probably very stressful it was
was it is you're still doing it right
yes
it is you're dressed like you're still
doing it yeah it is
what advice would you give to a young
girl who's considering doing this
just stay focused you know don't trust
everybody
you know how to use your brain your own
brain
you know you're going to be gas out
there manipulate you you know
manipulate us in all form fashion type
of way we just got to send this you know
stand up for ourselves
do what we supposed to do you know even
if it seems
wrong you know we have to follow what's
best for us
i don't recommend it for any young girl
because i worry about my
daughters and nieces and cousins you
know i'm saying you come across the
wrong
guy you know the gas crazy you know
you could be out you know have good
intentions on you know doing the right
thing but
soon things don't go their way you know
you get beat then
you know that leads to death and
you know all types of things and i heard
and seen
plenty of young girls you know kidnapped
so i just didn't want you know young
girls to go through what i went through
if i could try to set example if anyone
need you know me to talk someone
have socks on don't go through what i
went through
as far as pym drugs you know what i'm
saying
no tell me about how you met that first
pimp when you were 15.
he left me and a place where i
would have no idea i'm 15 years old i'm
still a child trying to be
grown you know smelling my tail
hanging with my cousins you know trying
to be grown
pimp crying across me just
know i was you know ceiling [ __ ] so
you know came and talked sweet saw me in
my ear i went forward
and it been hell there is something i
wish i would never did
do you think he tricked you into that
yeah he did he did but he was
coming on like coming onto you like he
was a boyfriend right
and then all of a sudden all of a sudden
i got to pay you
you beat me up you want to kill me if i
don't give you my money
you know so i came a long way because
i supposed to be dead but i'm living
testimony
yeah i'm supposed to be dead but i am a
living testimony
all right keisha thank you so much for
sharing your story you're welcome i wish
you the best of luck and good luck with
your kids too
i shall appreciate it thank you you're
welcome
that was great
you